Daenerys Targaryen is known by many titles,
and on the latest episode of Game of Thrones,
she gained another one, a name she insisted
she would never take on, as long as she could
help it.
Here's how the twist went down and what it
all means.
Daenerys admits she has only known fear in
Westeros, not the love that her nephew, boyfriend,
and potentially rival claimant to the Iron
Throne Jon Snow has come to receive.
This realization, combined with her newfound
knowledge that her Master of Whisperers Varys
committed treason against her in shifting
his loyalty to Jon, plus the recent death
of her trusted adviser Missandei, pushes Daenerys
past her breaking point.
The Mother of Dragons dives head-first into
the madness that her father, the so-called
"Mad King," suffered when he sat on the Iron
Throne amidst Robert's Rebellion.
In Episode 5, Dany became "The Mad Queen,"
destroying King's Landing and killing thousands
of innocent men, women, and children on her
mission to unseat Cersei Lannister and take
the Iron Throne herself.
"The Iron Throne.
Perhaps you should try wanting something else."
Dany time and again has stated that she's
not a carbon copy of her father, and she wouldn't
make the same mistakes he did.
"I am not here to be Queen of the Ashes."
But that's exactly what wound up happening
during this latest episode, in a moment many
viewers felt was a wild twist.
However, in the eyes of Game of Thrones showrunners,
Daenerys going mad wasn't exactly a big shock.
David Benioff and Dan Weiss explained during
the show's "Inside the Episode" featurette
that Thrones had long foreshadowed Dany's
spiraling into instability, and that there
are plenty of clues sprinkled throughout past
seasons that signaled this dark turn would
happen eventually.
One such clue is the death of Daenerys' brother,
Viserys, back in Season 1.
Dany didn't second-guess her decision to have
Khal Drogo pour molten gold over Viserys'
head and refused to look away when the deed
was carried out, wanting to watch him suffer
through the pain.
"He was no dragon.
Fire cannot kill a dragon."
Daenerys has a history of killing, or ordering
others to kill on her behalf, and exhibiting
no signs of hesitancy or remorse.
She burnt a witch alive and almost relished
in her cries; she sentenced people to die
in a vault and didn't think twice.
Daenerys also burnt a slave-owner alive and
was thrilled to do it.
She gave a chilling speech about how she deserved
to rule just before she burnt a horde of Dothraki
warlords to death.
And who could forget her ruthless flaming
of Samwell Tarly's brother and father, plus
her execution of Varys that came at the top
of this very episode?
The season has shown time and time again that
Daenerys isn't afraid of doling out death
sentences, and she's been pretty clear about
her intentions from the start.
"We will take back what was stolen from me
and destroy those who have wronged me.
We will lay waste to armies and burn cities
to the ground."
But that attitude contrasts harshly to the
other side of her personality, the side that
frees wrongfully enslaved people, liberates
cities, and promises to "break the wheel"
of oppression instead of simply taking her
own turn as the person in charge.
Dany turning into the person she said she
would never become, the woman who strikes
fear in the hearts of the Westerosi people,
the Queen of the Ashes, the spitting image
of her father, was shocking to behold even
if there were some breadcrumbs leading up
to the snapping point.
Dan Weiss has said he doesn't feel that Daenerys
always intended to burn King's Landing and
its citizens to a crisp, though there was
a lot of build-up that would show cause for
her doing so.
Rather, Weiss noted that Dany decided to take
that course of action the moment she arrived
in the capital city.
"It's in that moment on the walls of King's
Landing where she's looking at that symbol
of everything that was taken from her, when
she makes the decision to make this personal."
Benioff added that Daenerys may never have
become the Mad Queen if her journey to the
Iron Throne had played out differently.
"If circumstances had been different, I don't
think this side of Dany ever would have come
out.
If Cersei hadn't betrayed her, if Cersei hadn't
executed Missandei, if Jon hadn't told her
the truth..."
Unfortunately, this side of Daenerys Targaryen
did come out, and it will probably be her
undoing.
It's tough to imagine the people of Westeros
rallying behind Daenerys after she needlessly
murdered thousands of people via dragon fire
and decimated the capital.
Now that she's gone full Mad Queen, Dany likely
can't go back to the person she used to be.
Her dream to sit on the Iron Throne may never
come true, despite her greatest enemy, Cersei,
dying in the chaos of the siege and Jon constantly
saying he will always support Dany.
It will be an intense fight to the finish
during the final episode of Game of Thrones.
As Daenerys actress Emilia Clarke told The
Hollywood Reporter,
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones Season 8 are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.